[Music]
this was a story that i had been trying
to tell for 20 years literally and i was
just trying and trying to crack it and
it wasn't until i realized that it had
to be a documentary because
in making a documentary i would
be allowed to not know all the answers
to me as a trans person the thing that i
find most exciting about living in this
time in the future
is that these figures from the past um
re-emerge and liz
reached us they don't get enough
coverage already so you know the idea
that you might be the only one is um is
a big responsibility you led with a
values
ethics first approach to the filmmaking
not trying to do something extractive
that was really important to us
the like funny part of it is that like
we were not the weirdest thing happening
at the da's office my god is my editor i
pray to this editor that i never get to
see
most times i shoot something and it's
like
i hope he likes me i hope she likes me
i'll just pick a random folder right now
from this thousand hours and then
whatever that is i'll find a way to use
it that's how you do it
i can do this and i thought if i could
it would probably be the greatest
accomplishment i think of my life after
the after party yeah